un mot sur l'origine de cette initiative
nos collègues Valérie Boyer et Laurent
Burgoa que je salue on fait part au
président du Sénat de leur inquiétude
concernant le devenir de ce territoire à
la biodiversité exceptionnelle et au
modèle économique fondé sur le bon état
des écosystèmes
le président dans sa grande sagesse et
sachant l'expertise de notre commission
en la matière nous a confié le soin
d'assurer l'information du Parlement est
plus largement l'information des
citoyens sur les défis que le changement
climatique fait peser sur le territoire
camarguais
ce sujet peut paraître au premier abord
local ou anecdotique mais ce serait une
grosse erreur que de s'en tenir à cette
analyse la Camargue soulève un grand
nombre de questions question
d'importance nationale au travers de
problématiques que rencontre bien
d'autres territoires littoraux ainsi que
des spécificités propres à ce territoire
unique au monde premier site français
d'importance internationale reconnue au
titre de la convention de Ramza relative
aux zones humides et à l'habitat des
oiseaux or ce territoire est aujourd'hui
menacé menacé par la montée des eaux qui
favorise également la salinalisation des
sols ses effets du changement climatique
menacent donc les fragiles équilibres
d'un savoir-faire et traditions locales
je pense notamment au rôle original joué
par les maladies ainsi qu'on appelle les
éleveurs de troupeaux libres la culture
du riz la viticulture elle élevage de
taureaux et chevaux sont ainsi remis en
cause par ces évolutions
plus radicalement encore l'habitat de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'habitants et d'ici 2050 concernés par
le risque de submersion pour répondre à
ces multiples défis environnementaux
économiques et sociaux les forces vives
locales sont parvenues à s'entendre dans
le cadre d'une organisation efficace et
de mécanismes de coopération exemplaire
donc à Margue gardoise un syndicat mixte
a été créé en 1993 il associe les 8
communes du territoire camarguais au
conseil du département au conseil
départemental du Gard nous avons
d'ailleurs le plaisir d'accueillir mais
je pense qu'il va arriver et Robert
Croze se sont présidents dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône a été créé en 1970 le
parc naturel de régional de Camargue
dont nous accueillons le directeur
général Christophe fontfred
l'acuité de ces enjeux a poussé
l'inspection générale de l'environnement
et du développement durable et le
Conseil Général de l'alimentation à la
de l'agriculture et des espaces ruraux
amener une mission conjointe sur cette
situation c'est à ce titre que nous
avons convié Bruno cinotti coordinateur
de cette mission la Camargue doit
aujourd'hui relever un double défi il
est en premier lieu nécessaire dans
cette anticipé d'atténuer au mieux les
effets du changement climatique sur ce
territoire ces effets sont de deux types
la Camargue va d'abord faire face à des
épisodes extrêmes de plus en plus
nombreux et à une multiplication des
tempêtes qui s'accentueront dès la
prochaine décennie ce territoire doit
aussi faire face aux mouvements plus
diffus desrosions du trait de côte
répondre à ces deux types de menaces
nécessitent de nombreux aménagements
dont le choix est souvent complexe à
l'aune des connaissances scientifiques
disponibles à titre d'exemple la
construction de Dick peut protéger le
trait de côte à certains endroits mais
accélérer son recul
plus loin
toutefois ces efforts d'atténuation
risque de ne pas aboutir au maintien à
moyen terme de la Camargue tel que nous
la connaissons aujourd'hui face une
montée des eaux estimée entre 40 et 70
cm en 2100 il faut également prévoir des
mesures d'adaptation l'épineuse question
du déplacement de certaines populations
devra sans doute est envisagé dans les
scénarios prospectifs toute politique ne
prenant pas en compte c'est fait
conduirait à pénaliser ce territoire et
ses habitants un discours de je vous en
prie
un discours de réalité est donc
nécessaire sur cette question j'aimerais
entendre nos invités sur l'articulation
de ces deux sujets l'atténuation des
effets du changement climatique et
l'adaptation des activités humaines à
l'évolution de l'environnement en partie
inéluctable
il ne s'agit
là bien sûr que d'une première amorce de
réflexion pour engager le dialogue après
un propos liminaire de 5 minutes pour
chaque intervenant je laisserai la
parole à notre collègue Laurent Burgoa
pour une intervention liminaire avant
bien entendu la traditionnelle série de
questions et de réponses je vous donne
la parole je vous donne la parole à nos
invités qui veut commencer
allez-y Monsieur
Merci monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai donc coordonné une mission qui a
pris plus de temps que prévu
initialement et qui a bouclé son rapport
hier rapport qui devrait être transmis
très prochainement au ministre
commanditaire ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire et
ministre de la transition écologique
donc ce rapport sera normalement assez
rapidement disponible puisque nous
souhaitons vivement qu'il soit rendu
public parce que les rapports qui ne
sont pas rendus publics ne présentent
une guerre d'intérêt
j'ai mené cette mission avec deux
collègues nous on nous a demandé de ne
pas venir à trois c'est dommage parce
que nous avions des points de vue qui
était
convergents mais pas totalement
identique je vais essayer en quelques
minutes de vous dire ce que nous avons
compris du territoire avec cette
modestie de gens qui ne sont pas issus
de ce territoire et en même temps de
gens qui sont pour l'essentiel de leur
vie en région parisienne donc un peu
éloigné des enjeux qui se présentent sur
ce territoire c'est d'abord un
territoire compliqué je ne vous la
prendrai pas et ça nous a été résumé par
un par un camarguais sous le ce résumé
qui ne paraît tout à fait réaliste la
Camargue est un territoire naturellement
artificiel
c'est un territoire qui a depuis
longtemps été aménagé par les activités
humaines et donc un certain nombre
d'équilibre ont été atteints et ces
équilibres sont actuellement en
difficulté du fait de l'évolution des
événements c'est également un territoire
compliqué dans la mesure où les découpé
par l'histoire il y a une Camargue du
côté des Bouches-du-Rhône il y a une
Camargue du côté du Gard et il y a entre
les deux le Petit Rhône l'un des bras du
Rhône et il y a entre les deux un
certain nombre d'événements historiques
qui ne les ont pas toujours rapprochés
ensuite c'est un territoire menacé votre
Président vous le rappelait alors nous
sommes partis sur une hypothèse un tout
petit peu plus difficile qui est
l'hypothèse du scénario dit tendanciel
du GIEC scénario qui envisage une montée
du niveau de la mer en Méditerranée de
60 à 102 cm d'ici 2100 or la Camargue et
pour la majeure partie de son territoire
à une altitude inférieure à un mètre
vous imaginez tout de suite quel est le
télescopage entre cette élévation
progressive du niveau de la mer et la
réalité altimétrique du territoire
auxquels j'ajouterai mais on peut pas
rentrer dans le niveau de détail
nécessaire que comme le la Camargue des
Bouches-du-Rhône à l'intérieur du delta
entre les deux bras du Rhône n'est plus
alimentés par les alluvions elle a
tendance à s'enfoncer ce qui aggrave
encore le problème alchimétrique la
Camargue est menacée par quoi
historiquement elle était menacée
surtout par le Rhône et donc par les
eaux douces maintenant elle est encore
et le système d'endiguement a encore son
utilité il a encore montré lors des
dernières grandes crues du Rhône mais
elle est surtout menacée par l'eau salée
de la mer de diverses façons
troisièmement la Camargue est un
territoire équipé au sens ministère de
l'équipement du terme puisque depuis
longtemps en tout cas depuis Napoléon
III un système d'endiguement a permis de
réduire considérablement les impacts des
grandes crues du Rhône sur ce delta
camarguais et d'autre part et il a été
équipé dans une moindre mesure de dire à
la mer qui ont réduit l'impact des
submersions marines donc certaines
mesures le territoire était adapté
historiquement aux contraintes qu'ils
connaissaient le souci c'est que ces
contraintes sont en train d'évoluer ça
vous a été rappelé par votre président
et elles évoluent d'une façon qui ne
peut pas forcément être traité
uniquement par les solutions qui ont été
mises en oeuvre par le passé ces
contraintes elles sont de différentes
natures la première c'est la contrainte
de salinisation sainlinisation par la
mer et par le dérèglement climatique
parce qu'on voit très bien comment l'eau
de mer peut apporter du sel dans les
terres par-dessus en cas de submersion
par dessous avec la pénétration de plus
en plus à l'intérieur des terres de ce
qu'on après le biseau salé mais on
néglige également le fait que le
dérèglement climatique amène un
déséquilibre beaucoup plus important par
le passé entre des précipitations qui
diminuent et inévaporation qui est
l'augmente et fait d'une part de moins
de pratique adulation et d'une plus
grande chaleur donc on aurait besoin
d'apporter à la Camargue pour y
préserver un certain nombre d'activités
notamment deux activités agricoles
majeures que sont d'une part la culture
riziculture ou viticulture et d'autre
part l'élevage toutes les manades dont
l'existence nous est rappelée et qui
constitue un élément important de
l'image touristique de la Camargue pour
tout cela on aurait besoin d'apporter
plus d'eau douce de préférence
gravitaire parce que les coûts de
l'énergie ne vont pas aller en diminuant
et que c'est pas en pompant dans le
Rhône de l'eau douce que on va arriver à
traiter le problème de la Camargue donc
ça remet en cause une certaine manière
la façon dont sont organisés les digues
et la possibilité éventuelle d'ouvrir
des brèches dans les digues ou en tout
cas de manœuvrer des ouvrages dans les
Dick pour faciliter les écoulements
gravitaires
deuxième phénomène c'est le phénomène
d'érosion alors on parle souvent
d'érosion du trait de côte mais parler
des religions du trait de côte c'est de
parler que de la surface or il y a
également une érosion en profondeur les
fonds marins sont en train de s'éroder
dangereusement en particulier au droit
de la commune des
Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer et c'est
évident que s'il y a des ouvrages de
défense à la mer qui peuvent être faits
pour les deux communes les plus menacées
celles des Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer et
celle du Grau-du-Roi ces deux communes
ne peuvent pas être
protégés à n'importe quel prix le quoi
qu'il en coûte nous savons ce sur quoi
ça peut ça peut déboucher d'autant que
nous avons une fâcheuse habitude en
France de toujours raisonner en termes
d'investissement et d'oublier qu'une
fois qu'on a construit un investissement
il faut l'amortir et le provisionner en
provisionner le renouvellement et donc
autant les structures actuelles
permettent éventuellement de financer
l'investissement autant et vous le lirez
dans notre nous nous interrogeons sur la
capacité du cimadrem le Syndicat de
Gestion des digues a financer
l'entretien ultérieur des geeks qu'on
aurait reconstitué ça pose un vrai
problème de nature budgétaire la
troisième menace c'est la menace de
submersion elle a été évoquée ces
submersions du fait de l'évasion du
niveau de la mer et éventuellement du
fait des événements météoriques plus
intenses seront de plus en plus
fréquentes et surtout pénétreront de
plus en plus loin à l'intérieur des
terres une cartographie du BRGM qui est
disponible sur Internet mettent en
évidence que la pénétration des laisse
de plus haute eau à l'intérieur de la
Camargue pourrait concerner 80% du
territoire de la Camargue d'ici 2100 or
il ne vous aura pas échappé si vous
connaissez un petit peu le
fonctionnement du domaine public
maritime qu'au fur et à mesure qu'avance
les laisse les plus hautes eaux les
propriétés privées deviennent publics
sans indemnité
une mauvaise solution ce serait des
digues ce serait une mauvaise solution
en ce sens que alors de digue à la mer
pardon ce serait une mauvaise solution
en ce sens que créer un polder sur salé
parce qu'à l'intérieur derrière les
digues il n'y aurait plus assez d'eau il
y aurait toujours autant d'évaporation
on stériliserait encore plus rapidement
l'espace à l'intérieur des digues et
donc ça nécessite vraiment de se poser
la question de ce qu'on veut exactement
la deuxième chose c'est que face à cette
progression des submersions marines il
peut difficilement être question
d’autres choses que d'un retrait un
retrait progressif un retrait de
préférence programmée et non subi et
donc je vous renvoie pour cela un
rapport qui avait fait des collègues sur
l'érosion du trait de côte mais qui
envisageait toutes ces questions de
submersion marine rapport de 2019 qui
détaillait assez bien les possibilités
enfin un événement qui est lié aux
autres mais qui est un événement qui
doit être traité séparément c'est bien
l'élévation du niveau de la mer cette
élévation du niveau de la mer j'ai
commencé à vous en parler il a un effet
destructeur de valeur puisque d'un seul
coup des valeurs qui sont des biens
privés deviennent du bien public et je
le répète sans indemnisation et donc il
y a nécessité de s'interroger d'un point
de vue économique d'un point de vue
fiscal et d'un point de vue social sur
la façon dont on va partager cette perte
de valeur il y a plein de certitudes sur
ces différents phénomènes il y a une
énorme incertitude et c'est celle qui
paralyse un certain nombre d'actions
c'est le calendrier personne ne peut
dire si la du niveau des mers si
l'aggravation des submersions marines si
les multiplication des événements de
tempête va aller rapidement en
s'aggravant ou qu'on aura une
augmentation progressive ce qui est
certain c'est que on a choix entre deux
attitudes Louis XV après moi le déluge
mais on sait ce que Louis XV a apporté
comme malheur à la France ou gouverner
ses prévoir donc nous pensons et nous
essayons dans le rapport que nous avons
fait qui est stabilisé dans son écriture
depuis hier et qui sera transmis très
prochainement au deux ministres nous
pensons que il faut prévoir et que c'est
comme ça que nous gouvernement
collectivement collectivités
territoriale au premier chef et bien
évidemment collectivité nationale en
solidarité avec la collectivité les
collectivités territoriales voilà
monsieur le Président j'espère avoir
rapidement dans le délai qui mettait un
parti poser le décor de ce que nous
avons compris de la Camargue il y a
sûrement des imprécisions des
inexactitudes et nous sommes là pour
entendre les questions qui vont nous
être posées merci à tous merci Monsieur
Sinoti je vais donner la parole
maintenant à monsieur fonfred
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames messenatrices monsieur le
sénateurs laissez-moi vous remercier
déjà pour l'honneur que vous faites au
parc de Camargue en m'invitant donc je
vais pas reprendre les éléments qui ont
déjà été qui ont déjà été exposés
la Camargue pour parler de la Camargue
en fait je voudrais assister là-dessus
il faut parler de tout le bassin versant
du Rhône la Camargue c'est le débouché
du Rhône et donc tout ce qui se passe
dans le Rhône avant
tout ce qui se passe dans le Rhône avant
un impact direct sur la caméra donc ça
c'est vraiment une idée qu'il faut avoir
en tête on peut pas gérer la Camargue
qui est vraiment au bout de 800 km de le
Rhône c'est 800 km 810 km de longueur
c'est un bassin versant de 100000 km²,
tout ce qui est fait dans le bassin
versant du Rhône quelque part va se
retrouver au fil de l'eau dans la
Camargue que ce soit en quantité de
l'eau qu'en soit en crue en vitesse en
qualité de l'eau etc et ça c'est
vraiment extrêmement important parce que
ça explique aussi peut-être les tensions
les tensions sur le terrain que certains
camargués peuvent ressentir puisque ils
se sentent un petit peu vraiment tout en
bas d'une montagne ou l'eau des baroule
sur eux et ça peut générer un sentiment
d'impuissance sur place et c'est vrai
qu'il faut qu'on ait une vision globale
du système mode formation je suis
ingénieur agronome et quand on lutte par
exemple contre la contre l'érosion il
faut pas que la vitesse d'une goutte
d'eau dépasse 10 mètres par seconde et
donc vous commencez en fait à vous
commencez à lutter en haut du bassin
versant parce que si vous faites un
barrage une plantation en bas elle est
embarquée parce que l'eau arrive à toute
vitesse donc en fait il faut travailler
en haut quand vous avez travaillé en
haut petit à petit vous descendez
jusqu'en bas mais c'est comme ça que
vous arrêtez vous arrivez à lutter et
donc pour la Camargue c'est exactement
la même chose il faut commencer en fait
il faut vraiment avoir cette idée du
Rhône en tête il faut commencer ça se
joue tout le long du Rhône en fait pour
que dans la dans l'embouchure du Rhône
puisque c'est les Bouches-du-Rhône le
département c'est pas par hasard donc
dans l'embouchure du Rhône ça soit plus
facile à gérer on puisse gérer les aléas
climatiques qui ont été décrits plus
facilement donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très important et
notamment par rapport aux sédiments
en fait le territoire camarguais est un
territoire très mouvement c'est un
espèce de tapis roulant ou la mère
depuis des millénaires des centaines
d'années
emmènent les sédiments les effectivement
creusent les écartes mais en même temps
le Rhône amène des millions de tonnes de
sédiments et donc il y a un équilibre
entre les départs et les apports de
sédiments depuis les centaines d'années
et cet équilibre aujourd'hui les rompu
il est rompu parce que le Rhône a été
aménagé
les forêts ont été replantés dans les
bassins versants et c'est une bonne
chose vous me ferez pas dire que c'est
une mauvaise chose bien sûr mais ça a
des conséquences les barrages très en
amont dans le Rhône ont des conséquences
sur la Camargue etc et donc il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on ait une réflexion
globale en fait sur sur l'ensemble du
système aujourd'hui effectivement il y a
une érosion du tas de cause ça a été ça
a été décrit et montait du niveau de la
mer etc mais ce qui se joue aussi c'est
qu'en fait
on est même pas tellement certain qui
est plus d'érosion qu'avant ce qu'on
sait par contre c'est qu'il y a moins
d'apport sédimentaire et donc ce
déséquilibre là mais il existe
aujourd'hui alors on va pas non plus
remettre en branle tout les sédiments du
Rhône mais il y a peut-être des il y a
peut-être des idées et des solutions à
creuser à ce niveau-là
ça a été décrit aussi donc je vais je
vais pas y revenir non plus mais je
voudrais insister sur sur la donc
effectivement le niveau de la mer le
niveau de la mer monte la Camargue c'est
un triangle vous avez une digue qui
arrête le grand Rhône vous avez une
digue qui arrête le Petit Rhône et au
sud vous avez la digue à la mer
c'est un jardin ça rien de naturel au
sens où c'est pas la nature qu'il a créé
c'est l'homme qui l'a créé ce sont les
hommes qui l'ont créé et donc on est
dans un système complètement
artificialisé dont l'homme a
complètement pris en main la destinée et
en fait c'est là où c'est là où on a
quelque chose de très particulier
l'homme a réussi à créer alors au nord
effectivement je dirais un jardin à la
française c'est à dire de la riziculture
quelque chose d'assez ordonné et au sud
plutôt un jardin à l'anglaise avec des
managers des taureaux et des marais etc
mais tout ça est complètement le fruit
du travail de l'homme et quelque part
l'homme peut en être fier parce qu'il a
créé ce qu'on appelle maintenant des
zones naturelles tellement quand vous
êtes sur le terrain vous avez
l'impression que c'est naturel c'est
vrai la nature est là les oiseaux sont
là la biodiversité et là mais c'est le
fruit du travail de l'homme et c'est le
fruit du travail des agriculteurs aussi
c'est ça qui est extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'on est dans le territoire ou
l'agriculture et la nature sont
complètement imprégnés et en fait le
naturel je vais essayer de pas être trop
long
le naturel donc plutôt près de la mer au
sud du delta en fait et nourri par le
Nord qui est la riziculture qui en fait
va pomper de l'eau dans le Rhône de
l'eau douce et cette eau douce ensuite
elle va descendre dans les milieux
naturels et les nourrir aussi
il faut il faut bien comprendre que
l'eau agricole c'est à peu près autant
que toute l'eau de la pluviométrie
chaque année et donc on a on a cette ce
c'est complètement c'est complètement
imprégné et ça aussi c'est intéressant
parce que les camargas sont sont toutes
des experts en hydraulique c'est très
étonnant quand vous allez sur le terrain
les tout le monde sait comment gérer les
apports d'eau alors que c'est
extrêmement complexe et donc c'est il y
a une vraie il y a un vrai savoir-faire
sur place il y a un vrai savoir-faire
sur
les sur les les outils
alors je vais je vais revenir sur les
outils on va dire technique par rapport
à la montée à la montée du niveau de la
mer il y a des outils qui sont bien
techniques et donc on connaît bien les
défauts qui sont la protection en dur
c'est à dire vous faites une digue
chaque fois vous faites une digue ça
creuse dessous ça creuse sous les côtés
etc donc c'est ça peut être une solution
à certains endroits pas forcément à
d'autres après vous avez
ce que certains disent mais ça s'appelle
pas lutter c'est-à-dire on laisse faire
on laisse la mer rentrer et puis tout ça
va se dépatouiller il faut comprendre
qu'il y a quelques centaines d'années la
mer remontait jusqu'au nord du vacarest
c'est-à-dire la moitié du delta actuel
était sous la mer est-ce que c'est ce
qu'on veut en terme de de développement
et en termes de protection de la
biodiversité pas forcément ensuite il
peut y avoir des des outils qu'on
connaît pas encore et là il y a quand
même un rôle pour la recherche c'est à
dire
l'un des sujets dans la montée de la mer
c'est en fait l'énergie qui apporte les
vagues et cette énergie si on peut la
casser l'absorber avant qu'elle arrive
au moment où elle arrive sur le rivage
elle va avoir un impact bien plus faible
à niveau constant et donc il y a des
choses qui se font alors dans d'autres
endroits mais par exemple des récifs
coralliens qu'on va mettre en avant de
plage dans les dans les dans les
Outre-mer français qu'on va mettre 100 m
ou 200 mètres avant les plages etc je
pense qu'il y aurait c'est un territoire
où il y aurait moyen peut-être
d'aider à chercher des solutions
nouvelles qui peuvent être fondées sur
la nature ou pas pour essayer de trouver
des choses qui soient moins impactantes
que les lignes
ensuite il y a l'eau douce donc mon
voisin mon voisin l'a bien l'a bien
déclaré donc vous avez ce triangle
complètement artificiel vous avez la mer
qui est au sud et qui en fait la mer
s'arrête pas à la digue à la mer elle
rentre par dessous et en fait le jeu
depuis 150 ans c'est sur cette sur cette
eau de mer vous avez une lentille d'eau
douce et c'est dans cette lentille d'eau
douce que vous allez cultiver et suivant
la profondeur de cette lentille d'eau
douce mais si la lentille d'eau douce
fait un mètre ou 50 cm parce que des
fois on en est là vous allez faire du
riz si la lentille d'eau douce vous avez
réussi soit parce que vous êtes un tout
petit peu plus haut à 1 m 50 au dessus
du niveau de l'eau soit parce que vous
avez mis beaucoup d'eau vous allez
pouvoir faire un peu de blé
si vous avez encore un peu plus d'eau
vous allez essayer de faire de
l'arboriculture voir du vin et suivant
la montée en fait de l'épaisseur de
cette lentille d'eau et bien ça va
impacter directement les cultures et si
vous maîtrisez pas votre votre
profondeur de cette lentille d'eau
pour grande partie artificielle il va la
culture vous avez tout d'un coup elle
est elle vous pouvez plus la faire c'est
à dire que vous avez eu vous avez réussi
à maintenir depuis 50 ans suffisamment
d'eau pour faire de l'arboriculture et
puis là vous y arrivez plus soit parce
qu'il peut plus assez soit parce que
vous mettez plus assez d'eau du Rhône ça
parce que la mer monte soit parce que
les trois et là vos arbres
et là après c'est compliqué
donc sur les sur les sur la manière de
lutter pour pas revenir sur les aspects
techniques
il y a des forces vives en Camaria il y
a des gens qui qui ont une vraie qui ont
une vraie compétence c'est un territoire
extrêmement résilient c'est-à-dire que
il y a 150 ans en Camargue c'était du
mouton des chasseurs et puis tout d'un
coup tout a changé le
xylostera a tué tous les vignobles
ailleurs et en Camargue on a fait du vin
partout et on a fait il y a des gens qui
ont bâti des fortunes et qui ont bâti
des exploitations énormes maintenant
dans tous les masses moi j'habite dans
un masque en Camargue comme dans tous
les masses il y a
l'ancienne cave à vin en fait et
aujourd'hui il y a pratiquement plus de
20 parce que la situation a encore
changé et la plupart des gens maintenant
font du riz et on est sur un une filière
qui pourrait être à peu près à minima
rentable doit tourner à 15000 15000
15000 tonnes de riz donc c'est un
système qui est pas résistant mais qui
est résilient c'est-à-dire c'est un peu
comme le roseau de Camargue c'est un
système qui a su s'adapter mais avec des
changements extrêmement profond et c'est
pas un territoire vous pouvez être
résistant parce que la force de l'eau va
vous briser c'est pas le chêne c'est
plutôt le roseau donc ça c'est quand
même quelque chose de quelque chose
d'encourageant et dans ce cadre là si je
peux me si je peux me permettre
également le rôle de lapin qui est juste
fondamental alors le riz en France c'est
la Camargue donc c'est quelque chose qui
est pas forcément très connu c'est
quelque chose qui est pas forcément
facile à facile à défendre puisque c'est
un cas particulier donc évidemment la
lisibilité est pas forcément là mais
vous voyez pour pour lutter par exemple
je vous dis suivant la profondeur de la
lentille d'eau vous pouvez faire que
durée à certains endroits
si vous avez assez d'eau vous allez
pouvoir faire du riz bio avec des
rotations avec du blé avec d'autres
choses et donc vous allez pouvoir avoir
une qualité de l'eau en sortie qui va
être bonne et vous allez pouvoir
l'envoyer dans les milieux naturels qui
dépendent de l'eau de l'agriculture sans
problème la difficulté c'est que le bio
vous pouvez pas le faire partout parce
que si vous avez une lentille d'eau
vraiment très mince vous pouvez faire
que du riz vous pouvez pas faire de
rotation culturelle et là si vous pouvez
pas faire de rotation culturelle vous en
sortez pas en agriculture bio puisque
vous êtes obligé de faire du
traditionnel donc aujourd'hui la surface
agricole utile de la Camargue elle est
déjà à 35% en bio c'est quand même
quelque chose de c'est quand même
quelque chose de considérable c'est
aussi une piste de solution pour
désaliniser le les étangs puisque les
étangs qui sont au sud donc avec la mer
etc on a besoin de cette eau agricole on
a besoin de la remettre dans le milieu
naturel et donc il y a un enjeu sur la
qualité de l'eau et donc là c'est vrai
que des aides
qui serait orienté sur des pratiques
culturelles pas forcément bio hein parce
que il y en a d'autres qui sont qui sont
intéressantes aussi mais qui sont
forcément un peu moins rentables c'est
vrai que là aussi il y a il y a d'autres
endroits où on peut agir pour essayer
d'aider le système à résister à
s'adapter et en termes en termes de
science aussi je pense que c'est un
endroit pour pour la science
effectivement c'est un laboratoire du
changement climatique on est au premier
horloge c'est le plus grand delta de la
Méditerranée et je pense qu'il y aurait
vocation à avoir un renforcement
on a beaucoup de sciences privées
sur la zone ce qui est bien ce qui est
très bien mais on a besoin aussi d'une
science
je dirais institutionnelle avec une
réputation d'indépendance totale
vis-à-vis des heures et des autres qui
permettent d'objectiver le débat au
maximum voilà donc il y a effectivement
des pressions très importantes mais je
pense qu'il y a aussi des il y a aussi
des des
sources
d'encouragement ou de voilà et un
dernier mot pour dire que les camarguais
sont aussi en réussira pas sans eux je
suis pas camargué
mais on réussira pas sans eux et donc il
y a aussi un volet très très important
en termes de d'explication donc ça c'est
le rôle d'un parc naturel régional mais
ça demande aussi des des moyens il y en
a un investissement profond c'est à dire
quoi on a besoin aussi d'écouter l'or
diagnostic à eux parce qu'ils ont
peut-être aussi des solutions auxquelles
on pense pas forcément nous-mêmes
monsieur le Président j'étais trop long
merci merci
bienvenue monsieur cross je vous donne
immédiatement la parole ou je lui donne
la parole à notre collègue Laurent et
vous prendrez après comme vous voulez
n'est pas le temps de vous reposer
d'accord complètement tout à fait
allez-y merci président salutations à
toutes et à tous excusez mon retard donc
je suis auprès de vous en tant que
président du syndicat mixte de la
Camargue Gardoise est prêt à participer
donc je l'espère avec des contributions
utiles à votre réflexion je salue mon
sénateur de niveau ainsi que vivait
Lopez et Monsieur Burgoa ici présent
j'ai plaisir à retrouver
Laurent est-ce que tu veux un peu la
parole juste préserve tout d'abord pour
pour remercier le président Larcher et
vous-même d'avoir pris j'allais dire le
taureau par les cornes
du sujet du sujet Camargue qui est qui
est cher au sénateur des deux
départements des Bouches du Rhône et du
Gard et le gars est particulièrement
bien représenté ce matin avec mes deux
autres collègues bien sûr saluer Robert
crotte le président du Sénégal mix de la
canard oui on a souhaité pour faire un
peu historique c'est vrai que c'est une
discussion comme il nous arrive avec
entre nous avec Valérie Boyer où on a
évoqué le sujet de la Camargue pour tout
vous dire mes chers collègues c'était un
sujet qui qui a préoccupé l'Assemblée
nationale et il nous semblait à l'année
à l'autre que le Sénat chambre des
territoires devait également se
préoccuper de ce territoire de ce
territoire qui est un des emblèmes de de
la France et sur lequel il faut que tous
ensemble nous ayons une réflexion pour
pour son avenir alors c'est vrai que
c'est un territoire où la biodiversité
est magnifique c'est un territoire aussi
et vous l'avez rappelé les uns et les
autres
l'agriculture est très présente que ça
soit en termes d'élevage mais aussi en
termes de riziculture et viticulture en
sachant que quand même pour ces deux
domaines que sur la résurre viticulture
il y a quand même une diminution forte
de en matière de riziculture avec des
dangers c'est des sujets que nous avons
en discussion que vous avez encore
récemment
ensemble à travers des projets de loi
tout comme la viticulture pour être
information et je parle sur le contrôle
du président Krost qui connaît bien ce
sujet là aussi c'est des centaines
d'hectares de vigne qui disparaissent du
cause de la salinité des sols et puis la
Camargue c'est aussi pour nous un lieu
touristique et un lieu d'avoir
économique incontournable sur lequel
c'est aussi un label pour nos deux
départements un point important et moi
je me réjouis je tiens à remercier le
président Longeot et lançant les
administrateurs de la Commission
européenne durable avoir pris très
rapidement le sujet nous aura proposé
cette table ronde parce que il est
important que que le Sénat et cette
réflexion et que je sais que après cette
table ronde il sera certainement
envisagé dans quelques mois également
une visite sur place parce que il est
important que le Sénat est aussi une
réflexion en sachant que l'État est
présent on est aussi un lieu où des fois
nous critiquons
l'État mais moi j'étais à dire que je
vais parler pour le gars notre préfet du
Gard est très mobilisée sur le sujet aux
côtés puisqu'elle a donné ça me
permettra le Président si ils vont le
permettait de renvoyer la balle au
président cross puisque c'est le
syndicat mix de la camara-gardoise qui a
été missionné par par la préfecture du
Gard pour suivre ce projet là et je
crois que ce qu'il faudra on n'est pas
en période de vœux je terminerai par là
c'est que même si on est sur deux
départements différents sur deux régions
différentes
il faudra dans l'avenir que nous
travaillons ensemble dans une
coopération avec des entités différentes
qui sont le syndicatrice gardoise et le
parc régional mais il faudra qu'on ait
une vision globale dans tous ces
domaines là si on veut sauver notre
Camargue
oui président donc président du syndicat
mix de la Camargue ardoise qui a pour
vocation de la gestion des espaces
naturels sensibles et comme le disait le
président Burgoa qui a aussi un rôle
d'assemblée comme on a l'habitude de le
dire c'est-à-dire de mettre autour de la
table et c'est je pense une force de de
ces syndicats animés par les élus en
proximité accompagné de leur
parlementaire de mettre autour de la
table l'ensemble des acteurs et dans les
situations que nous vivons c'est sans
doute un élément fondamental
du rôle que joue les syndicats mixtes
sur sur les territoires face à des
enjeux l'enjeu étant clair sur ce
territoire comme dans bien d'autres
celle du dérèglement climatique et du
réchauffement climatique avec
des effets déjà perceptibles notamment
sur la montée progressive du niveau de
la mer puisque en 30 ans ce sont 7 cm de
plus qui qui ont été observés et ont
nous demande de nous projeter vous le
savez à 30 ans 50 ans et 100 ans
permettez-moi aussi de dire que je suis
président délégué de Lanelle association
nationale des élus du littorales et je
rencontre cet après-midi Yannick Moreau
le président maire des Sables-d'Olonne
et vous le savez à quel point
l'association aussi est mobilisée même
si elle a posé un recours sur
l'ordonnance
considérant que les textes devaient être
mieux travailler pour sécuriser
juridiquement et accompagner la
responsabilité des élus du littoral sur
cette question du de la montée du niveau
de la mer
ardoise premièrement la pression de la
mer elle est perceptible par l'avancée
du biseau salé et le déséquilibre entre
l'eau douce et le somates et l'eau salée
au bénéfice de l'eau salée aujourd'hui
qui impacte comme l'a dit le sénateur et
comme les élus et parlementaires ont pu
l'observer d'abord
l'agriculture car vous le savez la
Camargue elle est le fruit de la main de
l'homme qui au fil des années a drainé
et gérer l'eau et aujourd'hui avec un
impact perceptible notamment sur le
vignoble puisque les 3000 hectares d'un
vignoble valorisé en passe de devenir
AOP sable de Camargue a vu 300 hectares
disparaître complètement sous le coup du
sel et puis c'est un déséquilibre des
milieux
le pâturage notamment les prairies avec
ces élevages emblématiques que sont les
levage du taureau de Camargue qui est
aussi un AOP et du cheval et de la
biodiversité pour vous donner un exemple
sur le centre découverte du Scamandre
que j'ai l'honneur de présider nous
avons là sur les roselières du Scamandre
et du charnier les sites les habitats
les plus remarquables d'Europe sur les
hérons sans espèces de Héron parmi les
plus remarquables d'Europe ces milieux
sont totalement menacés et de
disparition la salinité atteint la
roselière aujourd'hui et cet habitat
naturel est en train de disparaître et
avec ça au-delà du fait de la
biodiversité c'est toute un paysage
toute une attractivité toute une culture
qui est menacée donc c'est pour cette
raison que nous devons nous nous
mobiliser alors bien entendu
on est dans un temps très particulier on
l'a bien compris avec une ferme volonté
de maîtriser nos acquis mais aussi la
responsabilité de regarder l'avenir qui
est pas très encourageant même si à
travers les politiques d'accélération
sur
donc l'énergie et la biodiversité
nous devons nous l'espérons maîtriser au
mieux l'augmentation de la température
et donc l'impact sur les milieux
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer et
bien
malgré ça nous voulons conserver au
mieux nos acquis en étant dans
l'intelligence aussi de l'adaptation
mais pas de l'abandon pas de l'abandon
il est une notion qui est celle de la
libre évolution nous
entendons bien qu'il y a des points qui
seraient inutiles
d'absolument défendre mais il y a des
points sur lequel nous vous voulons être
mobilisés même si c'est dans une
adaptation dans des pas de temps
je pense que 30 ans 50 ans 100 ans c'est
une bonne une bonne intention dans le
pas de temps mais nous ne voulons pas
être soumis à ce qui pourrait être vécu
comme un abandon voilà sur l'esprit
général des choses la gestion de l'eau
est fondamentale la gestion de l'eau
elle est fondamentale c'est la gestion
bien sûr du fleuve Rhône donc ça c'est
le fleuve et l'élément le fleuve qui
amène l'eau douce sur ce territoire mais
pas que fleuve Vidourle fleuve aussi
rivière comme le Vistre ça nous renvoie
à la question relative à la gymapi
gestion des milieux aquatiques et
prévention des inondations et submersion
marine la communauté de communautaire de
Camargue dont je suis président
abondent annuellement en frais de
fonctionnement pour les structures epdb
EPTB syndicat mixte si madre 900
000 euros par an donc il y a un poids
aussi sur sur ces collectivités que je
pense qu'il y a une réflexion aussi à
mener sur ce point donc voilà beaucoup
de choses en même temps je le conçois
mais
notre attachement nous élu et d'ailleurs
on s'est mobilisé syndicat mix sur la
camarguardose pour obtenir le
renouvellement du label Grand Site de
France que nous avons obtenu et dans
j'ai bien reçu la lettre de du ministère
de l'écologie pour nous dire qu'on était
labellisés donc voilà les enjeux notre
territoire et merci de m'avoir invité
pour pouvoir ici devant vous les
exprimer
merci à vous je vais donner la parole à
votre voisin à mon collègue Bruno Belin
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour votre exposé j'ai
l'impression et je reprends votre
expression sur gentil nos premières
loges du changement climatique ça a été
employé par l'un de vous j'ai
l'impression qu'on est sur la cas
concret monter des eaux risque de
submersion avérée je reprends là aussi
les propos qui ont été tenus avec la
hausse de la sérénité
baisse factuel de l'économie de la pêche
de l'agriculture face à ce cas concret
avec derrière et vous l'avez rappelé
et je pense que c'est peut-être un autre
élément la gravité du sujet des
déplacements de population qui sont à la
clé on parle de 50 000 logements d'ici
donc on est aussi sur un cas d'école
dans la gestion de l'eau en clair là la
Camargue ce qui vous est présenté ce qui
nous est présenté c'est peut-être le
début du jour d'après
c'est un cas d'école c'est un cas
d'espèces exceptionnel et extraordinaire
auquel on nous devons faire face est-ce
que à votre connaissance
situation en termes de gravité peut-être
mesurée est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
situations similaires ailleurs
qui veut répondre
si on sort de la Camargue
ce qui a vous connaissez des situations
je pense que c'est un sujet qui
effectivement est important sur la
caméra mais c'est un sujet aussi qui
doit nous interpeller
je pense notamment au territoire
d'outre-mer un département d'outre-mer
où
il y aura il commence à avoir le même
souci même problème et puis derrière
avec cette population qui s'est
immigration environnementale qui
effectivement
se fera
allez-y
merci Monsieur prison merci de votre
question monsieur le sénateur situation
similaire ailleurs oui et non similaire
situation similaire évidemment partout
où on est en bord de mer puisque
l'ensemble de la masse d'eau océanique
va monter avec des avec des rythmes de
montée avec des effets qui sont pas
forcément identiques en mer Méditerranée
et sur la façade
océan atlantique mais le résultat final
est le même et en même temps pas
forcément situation similaire parce que
vous rappeliez à juste titre que le
serema a fait une évaluation très
grossière et qui nécessite d'être affiné
sur une cinquantaine pardon oui c'est
une cinquantaine de milliers de
cinquantaine de
milliers de logements qui sont menacés
par le par la montée du niveau des mers
à l'échelle de 2100 d'autres estimations
sont moins dramatiques la chance et la
malchance de la Camargue c'est que ça a
été rappelé par plusieurs des
intervenants la Camargue est
effectivement essentiellement composée
de milieux naturels agricoles et donc en
termes de population menacée ce ne sont
pas plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'habitants en camarte ce sont très
concrètement les habitants de la commune
du Grau-du-Roi et les habitants de la
commune des Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer
éventuellement les implantations
humaines de la commune de
Port-Saint-Louis au débouché du Grand
Rhône donc en termes de bâti habité la
Camargue est dans une situation plutôt
plus favorable que d'autres portions du
littoral ou au contraire on a eu une
concentration de bâtihabitée sur un
linéaire très important donc oui il y a
tout autour du littoral français de
métropole et d'outre-mer il y a des
situations qui sont de même de même
gravité au regard de l'élévation du
niveau de la mer mais qui ne sont pas
forcément de même gravité quant aux
enjeux de destruction de valeur foncière
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure dans mon
propos
oui tu as demandé la parole vas-y
du département des Deux-Sèvres donc dans
les Deux Sèvres nous avons le marais
poitevin qui est donc la deuxième grande
zone unique humide de France et je vous
ai écouté avec intérêt de vous prie
d'excuser mentors mais j'ai écouté ce
qui a été dit à l'instant sur les
problématiques que vous rencontrez alors
les problématiques du Marais Poitevin
sont différentes à certains égards des
vôtres mais pour autant tout ce qui est
le maniement des eaux la mise en place
de la gymapi avec des différences là
aussi sont des préoccupations qui sont
communes et peut-être le plus
c'est sans doute chez vous également la
même chose le plus complexe c'est la
multiplicité des acteurs de ce
territoire
à tous les niveaux
administratifs
syndicat de propriétaire
relation avec
le mouvement environnemental relations
avec le monde agricole et donc nous
avons beaucoup de points communs
bon nous n'avons pas le problème que
vous avez eu avec la montée des eaux
maritimes
le dernier acte qui a été marquant sur
cette côte de l'Atlantique c'était la
tempête Cynthia qui effectivement sur
l'île de Ré notamment et sur une partie
du littoral avait occasionné
des dégâts importants mon mon collègue
Guigui en délit qui dans le département
de demander connu bien également le
marais poitevin pourra en témoigner donc
je souhaiterais personnellement que
puisque nous avons également sur cette
zone humide un parc naturel régional
Grand Site de France
que nous puissions nous rapprocher pour
évoquer je ne sais pas si ça a été fait
j'ai autrefois assiégé au sein du
conseil d'administration du Parc Naturel
Régional ça n'est plus le cas mais je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
comparer et que une rencontre entre les
structures de ces deux grandes zones
humides seraient quelque chose
d'intéressant je me permettrai de vous
contacter monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur pour que nous puissions en
discuter
merci Gilbert j'ai peut-être continuer à
donner la parole à Monsieur bois
merci président deux choses je pense que
les explications qui ont été données sur
la gestion de la Camargue de la Camargue
Gardoise en particulier parce que c'est
sénateur de ce département sont
importantes on a dans ce territoire là
des efforts financiers qui ont été faits
de plus de nombreuses années maintenant
je pense notamment au département du
Gard qui a acheté des hectares des
milliers d'hectares dans ce secteur
géographique je pense au Conservatoire
du littoral qui a acheté lui aussi des
milliers d'hectares tout ça a été confié
en gestion au syndicat mix de la
Camargue ardoise le président notre avis
Robert Coste et il y a tout un effort
qui est fait la pour maintenir une
activité économique sur ces territoires
effectivement autour du taureau de
Camargue on est tout à fait d'accord
autour d'agriculteurs autour d'éleveurs
qui sur ce territoire garde doit qui est
un territoire quand même difficile où la
gestion de l'eau vous l'avez dit vous
l'avez répété est assez compliqué assez
assez problématique d'ailleurs et il est
important de faire en sorte qu'on est
concerne vous avez parlé de riz je crois
que le riz aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un
plan fort sur le riz parce que
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
permet de faire baisser la salinité des
sols on a perdu beaucoup de dizaines de
dizaines d'hectares ces dernières années
pour une question de conjoncture
économique et de rentabilité du riz il y
a des expériences qui ont été menées je
me souvienne de cette expérience qui a
été menée il y a quelques années quand
j'étais à l'époque président du
département où nous avons accompagné un
riziculteur à faire du riz bio avec une
expérience où il mettait des canards
pour désherber le riz au milieu c'était
assez rigolo mais ça fonctionne
faut-il encore que là on puisse dans le
cadre d'un revenu qui soit décent pour
ces mêmes agriculteurs leur permettre
d'avoir des primes parce qu'ils sont ils
ne sont pas difficiles de prime pas
où les primes pas qui sont qui sont qui
leur sont donnés ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux qu'il faudrait
qu'elle soit je pense que nous
partageons cette analyse voilà il y a
des prix le pack monsieur mais il y a
pris il y a prime pas qui est primes
pack si vous voulez on peut en parler
pendant des heures moi j'habite un
département où les prive pas que c'est
aléatoire mais donc on peut en parler
tant que vous voulez mais pour pour
autant je pense que c'est une culture
qu'il faut continuer à développer après
nous sommes dans un secteur géographique
dans cette Camargue ou il y a les
différents intervenants qui ont des
comment dirais
des intérêts qui sont complètement
différents
effectivement il faut permettre à ces
agriculteurs qui sont sur le territoire
du livre mais il faut aussi permettre à
ce que l'eau du Rhône qui permet de
faire baisser cette salinité des sols
puissent être utilisé beaucoup plus de
musique que c'est que beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui sachant que dans le même
temps le débit du Rhône à fortement
baissé ces dernières années et que la
salinité de la mer remonte dans le Rhône
donc nous sommes dans un problème qui
est extrêmement complexe extrêmement
difficile à arriver pour autant je pense
que le président Robert Coste l'a dit
l'AOP de Camargue en termes de vin et
quelque chose aujourd'hui sinon op qui
va qui va avoir le jour et qui est une
chrétienne de produits de qualité mais
je pense que là aussi il y a Distel
quand même qui est concernée était en
Robert dit il y a 300 hectares de vigne
qui ont qui sont portes de problèmes de
la salinité des sols moi j'ai des
chiffres qui sont beaucoup plus
importants
donc aujourd'hui je pense que nous
devons prendre consciente effectivement
que la problème de la submersion marine
et vous l'avez très bien expliqué
monsieur le Président en nous disant
qu'effectivement c'était quelques villes
qui étaient concernées ce n'est pas la
Camargue en général qui était concernée
par ce problème en termes de population
mais nous avons besoin effectivement
dans un département comme le nôtre cette
activité touristique qui est non
négligeable au Grau-du-Roi était
importante pour nous mais aussi de
préserver ce milieu naturel qui est la
Camargue parce que en termes de
biodiversité ça a été dit je le répète
c'est un endroit exceptionnel voilà
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Calvé
merci monsieur le Président d'abord
féliciter l'initiative qui a été prise
par Laurent et que vous avez relayé
président et merci à tous les
intervenants moi je voudrais élargir un
peu le débat parce que je me souviens
très bien j'étais enfant quand Pierre
racine est venu dans tout le
Languedoc-Roussillon
enfin construire la grande motte et puis
toutes les stations jusqu'au Barcarès
aujourd'hui
nous sommes nous dans une situation très
compliquée au niveau de l'eau
précisé notamment les
Pyrénées-Orientales
cette année sont dans une situation
dramatique
critique dramatique et
tout à l'heure sénateur parlait des
prélèvements de l'eau sur le Rhône
j'ai interrogé la la directrice de
l'agence de l'eau les prélèvements sur
le Rhône faudra peut-être pas trop y
compter parce que le débit abaissé de il
y aura bientôt 40% de prélèvements déjà
sur le début existant donc
non non mais il est de chez vous il y en
a que duc qui a été fait jusqu'à
Narbonne à l'époque les Catalans moi
j'en faisais pas partie puisque je
commençais ma vie politique et j'ai été
tout à fait d'accord pour pouvoir
réaliser cette aqueduc qui devait
fournir de l'eau jusqu'à Barcelone et
donc à l'époque dans les périodes on a
dit pas d'inconnu parce que on ne veut
pas que les agriculteurs de l'autre côté
en Catalogne puisse produire des des
fruits et légumes etc etc bon quand je
vais pas revenir sur ça mais je dis
simplement que pour nous ce
la problématique de l'eau elle se pose
sur l'ensemble du poteau militarien elle
se pose pour l'alimentation en eau
potable elle se pose pour faire en sorte
que le biseau salé
n'entre pas dans les dans les
territoires et parce qu'il y a la nappe
n'est plus alimentée comme la plus
alimentée le Viso salé il rentre petit à
petit c'est une voilà et je dis que bon
ça c'était ce qu'avait fait Pompidou
avec Pierre racine heureusement il y a
eu Philippe lamour qui a qui faut rendre
hommage qui a su un moment donné utilisé
l'eau du Rhône mais pour l'avenir de nos
populations de pourtours méditerranéen
pour l'avenir de notre économie et de
notre tourisme c'est un moment
dramatique qui se prépare parce que soit
il y aura des déserts
soit il y aura au-delà des problèmes de
submersion marine mais il y aura un
moment où ça fonctionne plus je ne sais
pas quelle est la solution peut-être que
ce qu'on pourrait proposer dans notre
commission c'est de voir comment on peut
proposer un grand plan pour taux de la
Méditerranée pour l'alimentation à nous
pour la lutte contre le biseau salé pour
faire en sorte que ces territoires ne
soient pas dans les années à venir des
déserts j'exagère peut-être aujourd'hui
mais pas tellement pour nous en tout cas
voilà donc je pense que ça ça peut être
une proposition ou peut-être une étude
qui peut être faite
qui mérite en tout cas tout l'intérêt en
matière d'aménagement du territoire pour
nous voilà merci cher collègue j'ai
donné la parole à Jean-Claude là
merci président d'abord je voudrais moi
aussi me joindre au fait remercier le
sénateurs du garde d'avoir et Laurent
d'avoir amené ce débat ici finalement
et puis reprendre ce qui a été dit donc
à la fois par François et par Gilbert
j'avais deux questions en fait on est
bien on voit bien la connais autour
d'une construction humaine ancienne mais
humaine donc et j'avais une question
simple finalement comme nous sommes
entourés de trois digues je suis bien
compris et un territoire au milieu je
voulais mais c'est la question de
Gilbert comment s'organise la
gouvernance par rapport au problème
voilà c'était pour moi un sujet
fondamental quand il y a une crise il
faut qu'il gouvernance qui se met en
place et j'imagine que ce n'est pas
simple puisque vous avez bien décrit les
différents enjeux je me dis des fois que
sur le zan vous êtes à l'avance
finalement c'est un autre débat que nous
avons ici vous savez les zones
artificialisées sont arrêtés les
constructions donc vous êtes à l'avance
malgré vous c'est une bouteille ce que
je fais mais en tout cas c'est la
gouvernance ça me semble essentiel et je
comprends que ce soit simple et puis
j'avais une autre question je les enjeux
à venir c'était par rapport à la Pâques
mais alors c'est Denis en a parlé
Monsieur le Directeur vous avez évoqué
les pistes et
pardon moi je suis sénateur de l'Aveyron
il y a un sujet qui nous inquiète
beaucoup c'est le dernier rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui viennent à ce
produit de la Cour des comptes qui
s'intéresse aux vaches voilà pardon et
donc on imagine bien que par rapport à
la politique agricole commune il faudra
proposer de nouvelles choses et alors
vous avez évoqué les sujets alors je
sais pas que les sujets quoi vous pensez
que cetera connaissant un peu le sujet
voilà je me demandais quels sont les
idées que vous aviez sur ces
questions-là voilà c'est un peu précis
mais c'est ce que je voulais savoir
merci
monsieur le sénateur merci de Monsieur
sédator pour la question
je voudrais juste dire un mot sur les
sur les habitations etc j'ai noté dans
le débat effectivement les ce qui était
intéressant à avoir aussi en Camargue
c'est que quand il y a une innovation
les anciens masses sont pas inondés en
fait ils sont nos anciens construisaient
comme par hasard sur les bourrelets
allusionnaires et en cas d'inondation
complète de la Camargue les seuls
endroits qui sont pas inondés sont les
anciens masses des camarguais donc il y
a certainement des choses dans ce
domaine à creuser effectivement il y a
des points fixes il y a certainement des
points fixes à défendre et d'autres et
d'autres sur lesquels on doit on doit
reculer de manière plus aussi
intelligente que possible tout en
gardant en lien effectivement le rapport
il s'agit je viens à votre question
monsieur sénateur entre la biodiversité
et l'agriculture ce qui est vraiment
particulier
en Camargue et bon j'ai fait d'autres
postes ailleurs notamment en outre-mer
etc donc je connais assez bien le
réchauffement climatique un peu partout
mais ce qui est particulièrement
l'agriculture et la biodiversité c'est
nourrit l'autre la biodiversité
nourrissant elle-même le tourisme aussi
une autre activité une autre activité
humaine
et si on n'a plus d'agriculture en tout
cas dans le delta parce que c'est vrai
que la Camargue est pas seulement l'île
de Camargue c'est aussi les deux côtés
du rose du Grand Rhône et du Petit Rhône
qui eux sont bien sûr
pardonnier de la même manière
mais si on pense à cette imbrication etc
soutenir l'un ça peut être vraiment un
territoire d'expérimentation ou soutenir
l'un soutient l'autre où on n'est plus
dans l'opposition
un peu manichéenne entre agriculture et
biodiversité
l'élevage par exemple puisque vous
parlez de l'élevage effectivement on
parle des relevages très très extensifs
avec un taux de chargement à l'hectare
très très faible avec des troupeaux qui
en plus sont un rôle c'est-à-dire que le
Parc Naturel Régional on est nous-mêmes
opérateur on gère les terrains du
Conservatoire on gère 8000 hectares pour
le Conservatoire ce qui n'est pas sans
poser question puisque ça nous rend
aussi acteur
mais en tout cas les managers avec
lesquels on signe des beaux etc sont des
gens qui dans les troupeaux vont
entretenir l'espace en fait vont laisser
des prairies accessibles vont empêcher
la prolifération d'un certain nombre de
herbes qui sont pas forcément une bonne
chose pour pour la biodiversité donc cet
élevage là ce sénateur je connais
évidemment là l'impact de l'élevage sur
le réchauffement climatique il a il a il
a effectivement un impact mais dans ces
endroits là fait de cette manière là je
pense que peut-être que l'impact positif
peut excéder au moins au moins égaliser
les impacts négatifs donc après comment
on aide on va pas rentrer dans la dans
la mécanique budgétaire maintenant je
pense mais la même manière la
riziculture fait de manière correcte
contribue aussi à remettre de l'eau dans
le Vaccarès le Vaccarès c'est l'étang
central en plein milieu du Delta cet
état cet étang dont leur jeu en fait
Estelle ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que le sel c'est la taux de sel
dans l'eau donc la salinité et aussi
c'est le stock de sel au fond du au fond
de du Vacarès donc le Vaccarès c'est
15000 hectares de mémoire de et donc
c'est un lac salé
et aujourd'hui on estime qu'il y a trois
à quatre millions de tonnes de sel au
fond du lac
qu'il n'y avait pas il y a 10 ans
et il y a un moment protéger enfin il y
a enfant ça va tuer la biodiversité
si on continue à rajouter un million de
tonnes de sel tous les trois quatre ans
donc
et faire du riz faire du riz correct en
maîtrisant les effluents soit parce
qu'on fait du bio soit parce qu'on a des
pratiques culturales adaptées soit parce
qu'on fait des on est en train de tester
sur toute une partie du delta donc des
techniques de pour avoir des débats
sains de rétention qui permettraient aux
molécules de partir afin de se briser
avant de qu'on évacue l'eau dans le
bacares toutes ces techniques là
employées en même temps il n'y a pas de
solution magique sinon on l'aurait
trouvé il faut il faut faire plein de
choses en même temps en fait et je pense
que oui l'agriculture elle a un rôle et
je pense que
elle mériterait elle mériterait d'être
un peu plus soutenu pour ces pour ces
raisons là
merci Salut le directeur du parc donc
d'une part et répondre à votre question
sur la question de la gouvernance qui
est qui est essentielle donc vous l'avez
compris
la Camargue du Corot Daniel avec le parc
régional de Camargue et le syndicat
mixte de la Camargue ardoise donc la
Camargue bucco rodanienne qui est
maintenant depuis Arles jusqu'à
Port-Saint-Louis du Rhône et jusqu'au
petit Rhône dans le finalement le
périmètre qui a été dessiné par par ce
Rhône protégé et endigué et puis la
Camargue ardoise qui plus à l'ouest et
nous avons au Grau-du-Roi Port-Camargue
une ancienne branche du delta on en
avait parlé lorsque vous êtes venu
monditionné au Grau-du-Roi dans le cadre
de la commission
cette cette partie donc
qui est plus peuplé un petit peu plus
peuplé que que la partie bu
corrodanienne dont là le syndicat mix de
la Camargue ardoise dans les deux cas
implication dans ces structures des élus
pour la Camargue ardoise
l'ex-président de bois d'en parler tout
à l'heure le Conseil départemental en
rôle essentiel puisque
il est le contributeur avec les communes
mais le contributeur majeur des frais de
fonctionnement du du syndicat avec un
bon niveau d'implication des élus locaux
réellement je le préside aujourd'hui en
tant que conseiller départemental du
Gard bien entendu
la région est présente par rapport donc
assez politique et public sur
les zones naturelles et également
relation permanente avec les DDTM les
Dréal et puis il est un outil que nous
souhaitons animer on en a parlé avec la
présidente Agnès a juste petit donc dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône qui est
la réserve de biosphère de Camargue qui
embrasse le périmètre de ces deux
camargues être avec lequel cet outil on
voudrait animer
notamment en observatoire de la sanité
c'est un des éléments
je mets l'accent sur le fait que que cet
outil réserve de biosphère
n'a pas de réel ressources financière et
que ce sont souvent sur le les
ressources des syndicats ou des parcs et
du temps de travail pris sur les agents
de ces de ces structures que l'on peut
animer cela donc voilà un élément que je
voulais vous donner en tout cas très
prochainement la conférence des maires
va se réunir à l'échelle de la réserve
de biosphère et on aura autour de la
table les élus gardois et bucco
rodaniens je crois que c'est un point
important je vais insister et revenir
sur la question de la résiculture et de
la gestion de l'eau et nous avions
interpellé nos sénateurs sur la question
du coût de l'électricité pour les pompes
qui sont actionnées par les as dans le
vous le savez les asaas jouent en rôle
déterminant certes pour l'agriculture
mais aussi pour le réessuyage en cas
d'inondation et et là les ASAS sont dans
un équilibre extrêmement précaire par
rapport à l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie
l'idée étant peut-être de travailler sur
un prix entre guillemets encadré
préférentiel pour pour les ASA donc on
avait fait cette suggestion parce que
quand on rencontre aujourd'hui le
président des Zaza ardoise il nous dit
j'ai les moyennes d'actionner mes pompes
pendant trois heures au-delà nous
n'avons plus les moyens donc voilà c'est
un point quand même qui me paraît
crucial
et important pour moi à vous livrer vous
parlementaire dans cette enceinte
si bien s'il n'y a plus de questions je
vais je vais libérer nos interviens oui
Didier Didier
oui merci Président je vais prendre la
parole puisque la Vendée était cité moi
je suis effectivement sénateur de Vendée
tu es parti sûrement qui était comme les
Charentes maritime d'ailleurs meurtri
par la tempête Xynthia
la Camargue que je connais un peu pour
être entre autres récemment général de
la neige au Grau-du-Roi et puis voilà
par la petite personne également
concentre en fait tous les sujets
que ne connaissent pas d'autres
départements d'autres régions en dehors
du fait qu'effectivement sur le marais
poitevin de département de région
administrative donc on connaît un peu la
les trois départements et de région donc
un peu la complexité
moi ce que je vous suggère alors ce que
je sais pas si ce sera fait mais sous
l'égide du Conseil national de la mer et
du littoral la ministre a créé
comité national du trait de côte auquel
je participe entre autres avec Yannick
Moreau le président de Lanel
au titre du Sénat en tant que président
du groupe mère édit et donc je suggérer
que que ce rapport vous est transmis
puisse être regardé de près dans le
cadre de cet instant et puis qu'on
puisse éventuellement on va voir avec la
canal et éventuellement groupement
électoral et la Commission on a prévu un
déplacement mais que qu'on élargit un
petit peu le le les invitations entre
guillemets pour pour vraiment
appréhender parce que pour moi c'est
c'est plus qu'un laboratoire c'est quand
on parle à la fois de l'érosion du trait
de côte avec l'élévation des niveaux de
la mer et le risque de submer sur Marine
qui sont pas les mêmes sujets
s'ils sont étroitement liés mais je
pense qu'on pourrait se servir de la
Camargue comme un support facilement
expression vraiment intéressant comme le
disait Bruno également c'est vraiment le
cas d'école sur les enjeux qui sont
palpables et mesurables dès aujourd'hui
c'est pas demain dans ou dans 100 ans
c'est dès aujourd'hui
voilà une suggestion monsieur aussi
nautique je sais pas si c'était prévu
mais en tout cas qu'on puisse
bénéficier de ce travail
je vais donner aussi la parole parce que
je m'excuse parce que j'ai pas vu quand
j'ai le préavis il avait sollicité la
parole et puis vous répondrez et après
je donne la parole à notre notre
collègue blanc et puis vous répondrez
aux trois questions à la parole est à
Madame Préville merci monsieur le
Président merci à nous intervenants sur
ce problème évidemment si crucial qu'on
va devoir affronter et j'avais une
première question est-ce que puisque
ailleurs dans le monde il se passe
évidemment des phénomènes similaires
alors peut-être que le delta du Rhône
est particulier mais est-ce que puisque
de la riziculture il y en a ailleurs
dans le monde est-ce qu'il y a vous êtes
déjà penché sur la question pour
regarder les éventuels solutions qui
pourraient être apportées j'ai une
question sur la qualité de l'eau sur la
est-ce que ça la qualité de l'eau a
beaucoup changé est-ce que vous avez vu
des évolutions par rapport à cela sur la
baisse du débit du Rhône puisqu'elle est
actée est-ce que vous vous voyez que
c'est que cela vient du changement
climatique très globalement ou bien des
installations qui ont été faites
récemment sur le Rhône et du
questionnement qu'on pourrait avoir sur
ces installations vous avez parlé des
investissements sur les digues et j'ai
cru comprendre que ce serait compliqué
parce que ce serait très coûteux et quel
serait très globalement les futurs
scénaris d'adaptation est-ce que vous
avez parlé de triangle est-ce que ce
triangle devrait se déplacer un peu vers
le nord est-ce que c'est déjà envisagé
que bien évidemment comme l'eau va
monter qui guait d'autres zones qui
seraient le futur Delta je ne sais pas
est-ce que ça parce que je vous en avez
pas parlé et puis également sur alors
vous avez parlé aussi des des anciens
masses qui sont sur des bourrelets
d'alluvions est-ce que les communes les
villes du Grau-du-Roi et
Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer quelque part
serait quand même protégé parce qu'elle
serait un peu au dessus et pourraient
rester
tel qu'elles sont comme lieu touristique
peut-être je ne sais pas et voilà mes
questions et sur la population dans ce
qui est au nord de ce triangle est-ce
qu'il y a une population parce que pour
le coup moi je connais pas bien est-ce
qu'il y a une population importante qui
serait impactée également par le le
déplacement quelque sorte de ce delta
voilà
et puis après à nos intervenants pour
répondre Étienne oui merci monsieur le
Président Étienne blanc sénateur du
Rhône entre les Lyonnais et les
camarguais il y a depuis 1711
je dis pas un litige mais une sorte
d'incompréhension puisque à l'occasion
de la grande crue de 1711 le roi est
ensuite le régent avait décidé de taxer
les Lyonnais pour financer les digues de
la Camargue voilà
mais je voudrais vous rassurer tout ça
est prescrit et et en tout cas la
l'incompréhension politique est
aujourd'hui réglée non moi j'avais une
question l'endiguement du Rhône tous les
travaux qui ont été faits notamment par
la CNR ont diminué les cours
allusionnaires sur la Camargue
mais il en existe toujours ne serait-ce
que quand les barrages sont purgés je
parle de Génissiat et puis ensuite tous
les barrages subséquents
en même temps nous avons une
augmentation du niveau de la mer est-ce
que vous avez quelques chiffres pour
nous dire ce qui compense quoi dire ce
qu'on gagne par la lutvillonnaire et
qu'on perd par le niveau de la mer
est-ce que aujourd'hui tout ça c'est
chiffré j'imagine que ça peut chiffrer
au mètre carré près mais est-ce qu'il y
a quelques études prospectives sur ce
sujet là et s'il y en a
quelles sont sur la biodiversité les
conséquences que l'on peut
essayer d'en tirer par anticipation
et qui se lance en premier
merci beaucoup pour cette salle de
question vous avez toute la journée
devant vous je crois
plus sérieusement je vais essayer de d'y
répondre très factuellement ailleurs
dans le monde oui y compris sur le
bassin méditerranéen nous avons pris le
temps de faire un peu de comparaison de
parangonnage et nous avons observé ce
qui se passait sur les Delta du pot et
de l'Èbre le delta du pot était d'autant
plus intéressant que c'est une grande
zone resicole italienne ça a soulevé
deux questions d'abord les mêmes les
mêmes attitudes de déni dans les
populations ce qui pose un vrai problème
et on est complètement dans le après moi
le déluge donc je sur lequel je
géronisais tout à l'heure et en ce qui
concerne delta du pot ça amène des
comparaisons qui ne sont pas toujours
très flatteuses sur la façon dont la
France mais en œuvre la politique
agricole commune puisqu'il semblerait
c'est à vérifier mais vous avez
peut-être plus d'informations que nous
puisque ma chaudière de transition
écologique pas au ministère de
l'Agriculture il semblerait que la façon
dont la France met en oeuvre la Pâques
par rapport au riz soit beaucoup moins
favorable que la façon dont l'Italie est
dans une moindre mesure l'Espagne ou le
font le président du Centre français du
riz dans son rôle syndical tout à fait
honorable nous disait que ça pouvait
aller lui simplement double quand on
rapportait l'aide à l'hectare ça pose
vraiment question
néanmoins notre collègue du ministère de
l'agriculture au sein de la mission n'a
pas souhaité qu'on en fasse une
recommandation
ailleurs dans le monde
ailleurs dans le monde la seule chose
que je pourrais vous dire c'est toutes
les zones bases sont menacées dans le
monde entier il a des Delta qui ont des
ampleurs bien plus dramatiques que le
delta de la Camargue et avec des
concentrations de population également
dramatiques je pense en particulier au
Bengal Bangladesh en terme politique le
delta du fleuve alors je suis désolé je
suis pas toujours très bon géographie
mais le delta du fleuve qui forme la
toute la partie sud du Bengale et depuis
déjà des années et encore plus
actuellement inondé très régulièrement
et là ce sont des déplacements non pas
de de milliers ou de dizaines de
milliers de population mais des
déplacements de millions de population
et les les gens qui lisent les rapports
du GIEC s'intéressent particulièrement
aux conséquences sociales et
sociopolitiques de ces déplacements de
millions de population qui sont
évidemment un énorme déséquilibre pour
la géopolitique mondiale je m'engagerai
pas plus
sur la qualité de l'eau j'espère que
vous pourrez lire rapidement notre
rapport nous nous sommes interrogés à la
fois sur la qualité de l'eau qui arrive
dans le Rhône parce qu'elle n'est pas ce
n'est pas une eau pure venant
directement des sources d'Évian et donc
il y a une charge non négligeable en
polluant elle est acceptée par les
professionnels agricoles elle est
beaucoup moins bien acceptée par les
gestionnaires des grands espaces
naturels qui sont à Laval des bassins
agricoles en particulier le gestionnaire
de la réserve naturelle nationale du
Vaccarès voudrait qu'on lui apporte de
l'eau pure et serait prêt à prendre
directement de l'eau un petit peu
polluée du Rhône pour ne pas avoir la
charge en pesticides qui lui arriverait
des zones cultivées par la riziculture
je pense qu'il y a un vrai sujet dans la
mesure où les uns et les autres n'ont
pas su se mettre d'accord sur un
observatoire de la qualité de l'eau à
l'entrée du Vaccarès et ça fait partie
des questions que nous nous posons dans
ce rapport sur la baisse du débit du
Rhône par rapport au changement
climatique il est évident que la fonte
de plus en plus rapide des glaciers des
Alpes va probablement baisser le niveau
du Rhône surtout avoir un effet beaucoup
plus dévastateur sur l'agriculture qui
est actuellement le Rhône à un régime
nival un régime glaciolival et donc son
etiage est soutenu par les fentes
glaciaires et retardé au mois de
septembre or nous observons ces
dernières années que les tirages du
Rhône intervient de plus en plus tôt et
qu'il va bientôt intervenir au moment
précis où la température et la
climatologie rendent l'eau la plus
nécessaire pour les professions
agricoles l'un des problèmes principaux
de l'irrigation c'est que les
agriculteurs souhaitent irriguer au
moment où la nature n'apporte pas d'eau
le Rhône jusqu'à présent fournissait
cette eau précisément à ce moment-là ce
sera de moins en moins le cas le tiage
du Rhône s'avancera continuera s'avancer
en saison et bientôt au mois de juillet
voir dans la pire des hypothèses mais là
il y a pas d'études qui les paye
sérieusement mais il faut quand même se
poser la question au mois de juin et à
ce moment là on aura un énorme problème
puisque la priorité des priorités c'est
l'eau potable la deuxième priorité des
priorités c'est le refroidissement des
centrales électroniques et que aussi il
reste de l'eau il faut en laisser un
tout petit peu dans le fleuve pour qu'il
continue à avoir un minimum d'effet et
qu'il ne devienne pas un nouette dans sa
partie basse donc ça remettra en cause
très probablement l'utilisation de l'eau
du Rhône par l'activité agricole quel
que soit les traités qui ont été fait
une époque où on pouvait se permettre de
réserver une part de l'eau du Rhône à
l'agriculture
le cas échéant vous pouvez sur ce point
consulter le rapport public sur le
projet au a UTS de Provence rodanienne
dans lequel nous avons envisagé que pour
les 20 prochaines années il y aura
encore de l'eau pour financer les
projets d'irrigation qui seraient
immédiatement rentables dans le nord du
département du Vaucluse et le sud du
département du lieu de la Drôme mais
qu'en revanche au-delà de 20 ans il
fallait pas compter sur l'eau du Rhône
pour pouvoir rentabiliser ses projets
troisième question vous avez posé la
question des investissements c'est une
question générale de gestion des
équipements publics nous sommes un pays
qui fonctionne beaucoup à base de
subventions sur les investissements
parfois de prêts à taux zéro sur ces
équipements mais qui oublient toujours
que une fois qu'on a construit un
investissement il faut amortir cet
investissement il faut en provisionner
le renouvellement bah oui on passe du
budget d'investissement d'un seul coup
budget de fonctionnement nous savons
tous combien les budgets de
fonctionnement sont tendus et
malheureusement et c'est un des points
que nous avons observé sur le cimadrem
largement financé par les dispositifs de
subventions pour reprendre un certain
nombre de digues et y faire des travaux
importants nous avons observé et le
directeur du syndicat nous en est donnée
acte que le syndicat serait dans
l'impossibilité totale d'amortir les
équipements en question et on peut pas
fonctionner en investissant tous les 100
ans massivement et en laissant ensuite
les choses se dégrader tranquillement
faute de capacité de financement donc
c'est ça le vrai sujet au passage comme
c'est aussi ma spécialité c'est
exactement le même problème avec les
fameux réseau d'eau potable sur lequel
grâce au système des agences de l'eau
les collectivités territoriales ont pu
investir mais ont oublié de respecter la
M14 et d'amortir et provisionner les
équipements en question et du coup
reviennent redemander des subventions
d'équipement ça pose un problème vous
avez ensuite parlé de l'extension du
triangle camarguais si le Rhône baisse
en débit ne serait-ce qu'un peu et si la
mer monte oui il y aura peut-être des
refassonnages du delta du Rhône mais je
pense qu'on est à l'échelle des temps
géologiques et pas à l'échelle des temps
historiques donc là dessus je
m'avancerai vraiment pas vous avez la
poser la question des communes
protégeables
je l'ai évoqué un tout petit peu dans
dans ma première intervention la
question est toujours de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on veut protéger quelle est
la valeur qu'on veut protéger et quel
est quels sont les moyens notamment les
moyens financiers qu'on veut se donner
pour se protéger si d'ici 2100 la mer
monte de 60 à 100 cm comme c'est
envisagé dans le scénario temps
essentielle du GIEC il est évident que
tout ce qui est autour de la commune des
Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer et tout ce qui
est autour de la zone urbanisée de la
commune de Grau-du-Roi va se trouver en
partie submergée soit de façon
permanente soit en tout cas de façon
fréquente et donc que il sera difficile
de maintenir deux îlots de
d'urbanisation sauf à faire des très
grosses dépenses de défense à la mer et
je vais vous rappelle la loi du 18 16
septembre 1807 joliment écrite dans son
article 33 qui n'a pas été abrogé alors
que tout le reste de la loi portait sur
le dessèchement des marais et donc été
abrogé lorsqu'il s'agira de construire
une digue à la mer ou au fleuve la
charge en sera supportée par les
propriétaires des propriétés protégées à
du concurrence de la valeur des
propriétés
c'est sûr que quand c'est les autres qui
payent on a beaucoup pas envie de se
protéger quand c'est soi-même qui devons
quand c'est nous-mêmes qui devons
réfléchir à la valeur de notre bien et à
combien nous sommes prêts à dépenser
d'un seul coup l'équilibre de la
réflexion microéconomique si on ce qui
est malheureusement très mal enseigné en
France y compris dans l'enseignement
secondaire où elle devrait être
enseignée à tout le monde c'était
équilibre microéconomique et fondamental
en matière de prise de décision on n'est
pas dans la macro on n'est pas dans les
grands équilibres on est dans l'analyse
au cas par cas des projets donc oui tout
est protégeable mais à quel prix et
surtout quel prix sommes-nous à payer et
prêts à payer et surtout avons-nous déjà
en tête l'intention de faire payer la
solidarité nationale ce qui je reprends
les termes du rapport de 2019 sur le
trait de côte serait socialement
profondément injuste
voilà pour les questions que vous aviez
posé en rafale madame j'espère avoir
répondu à tous ceux sur quoi je suis
capable de répondre les deux autres
interlocuteurs le feront aussi je me
permets de terminer avec endiguement du
Rhône et diminution des alluvions
les différents ouvrages qui se trouvent
tout au long du Rhône ralentissent
effectivement l'écoulement des alluvions
mais ne l'empêche pas totalement et vous
avez raison à chaque fois qu'on procède
à la mise au sec et à la purge des
alluvions aux différents niveaux
auxquels on stoppe le cours du Rhône
habituellement les alluvions sont
reprises mais on ralent on ralenti quand
même ce flux des alluvions et donc de ce
fait la Camargue est beaucoup moins
rechargée qu'elle ne l'était à l'époque
où le Rhône fonctionnait en situation de
d'écoulement libre il faut pas oublier
non plus que les remarquables travaux
qui ont été menés au 19e siècle sur le
reboisement et la restauration des
terrains en montagne ont permis de
ralentir considérablement les phénomènes
érosifs dans le massif alpin et dans le
Massif Central et donc d'une manière
générale autant à une époque on avait
c'est un peu trop loin dans
l'exploitation de la montagne dans le
dans le fait de dénuder les sols et donc
de favoriser l'érosion autant grâce à
toutes ces actions qui ont été menées et
qui continuent à porter leurs fruits
parce que là on assume mettre l'argent
pour entretenir tous ces équipements de
restauration des terrains en montagne on
a donc bien ralenti l'érosion de la
montagne et donc de fait réduit aussi la
charge allusionnaire de du Rhône et puis
la toute dernière question c'est la
question de l'augmentation du niveau de
la mer par rapport à l'enfoncement de la
Camargue non il y a pas d'étude qui
chiffre d'une façon raisonnablement
précise la contribution des deux
phénomènes l'un par rapport à l'autre ce
qui est certain c'est que le biseau salé
progresse déjà le coin salé dans les
deux bras du Rhône est déjà très loin
puisque il s'approche de plus en plus
dangereusement de la Confluence
c'est-à-dire du Nord d'Arles et donc les
deux bras du Rhône sont de plus en plus
salés dans leur partie inférieure et
pour l'instant on arrive à prélever
encore de l'eau douce dans le Rhône
parce qu'on prélève au-dessus mais on
peut on peut plus prélever au fond parce
que l'eau il est déjà salée si la
Camargue continue à s'enfosser un temps
soit peu ce sera autant de centimètres
de profondeur qui nous poseront des
problèmes alors il y a une évocation des
coûts de pompage électrique monsieur
Crau ce n'était pas là quand je vous
l'avais dit nous pensons s'il y a un
avenir à l'utilisation de l'eau douce du
Rhône nous pensons qu'elle doit passer
impérativement par une modification des
circuits gravitaires parce que si on se
met à dépenser les sommes folles en
énergie à une époque on sait que
l'énergie va forcément continuer à
augmenter et peut-être augmenter
dramatiquement c'est vraiment pas le
moment de se mettre à se rendre
dépendant de dispositifs énergétiques
très coûteux donc il faut faire du
gravité c'est pour ça que je parlais de
peut-être ouvrir des brèches dans les
digues du Rhône ou y ouvrir au minimum
des vannages qui souhaitent actionner
pour permettre à l'eau tant qu'elle est
encore douce dans les parties où on peut
la prélever de la prélever ou en temps
utile
voilà pardonnez-moi le la rafale de
réponse j'espère avoir abordé un salon
de choses mais les deux autres
interlocuteurs précisons et apporteront
sûrement des éléments très
complémentaires
je pense que monsieur sinoty a apporté
de nombreuses réponses à vos questions
madame je vais pour y répondre
simplement et permettez-moi de le faire
d'écrire ma commune le gros du rapport
Kama donc le gros du roi Port-Camargue
c'est une ville où vivent 8500 résidents
permanents
c'est une ville littorale balnéaire qui
a une capacité d'accueil touristique de
150 000 lits elle est le fruit du
développement ça a été cité de la
mission racine notamment à travers la
réalisation du plus grand port de
plaisance d'Europe Port-Camargue 5000
bateaux
5000 bateaux et du plus grand port de
pêche de Méditerranée française avec la
plus importante flottille chalutières de
18 bateaux sur ce territoire
au cœur
de la Camargue ardoise
en vous disant cela bien sûr j'en
rajoute sur la question de l'enjeu de la
montée des eaux et vous avez évoqué
le zan sur sénateur de l'Aveyron
a été évoqué également mais pas tout à
fait la question de la recomposition
spatiale du repli stratégique
vous imaginez parce que à travers ce que
moi je vous raconte de cette petite
commune du droit méditerranéen ce qu'il
en est à l'échelle mondiale n'est ce pas
donc voilà nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
cette situation
et on nous demande à nous les maires de
tracer des cartographies
à 30 ans 50 ans et 100 ans sur de base
de données et oui il y a des études
nombreuses qu'il faut compiler et des
études nouvelles j'ai quand même bien
noté
caractère un peu incertaine de l'étude
du cerema qui nous a été proposé qui au
gros du roi donc m'indique que 1650
appartements seraient rayé de la carte
en 2100 d'accord donc on a bien sur la
volonté avec le président
Moreau avait lequel j'étais au sable
d'Olonne pas plus tard que ce week-end
pour soutenir l'équipage du Défi des
ports de pêche du Grau-du-Roi qui on
s'excuse à gagner l'épreuve
et bien avec la neige bien sûr nous
sommes totalement mobilisés sur sur
cette question mais lorsqu'on me demande
à mort Robert cross de tracer à 30 ans
50 ans et 100 ans je suis volontaire
pour travailler là-dessus accompagné
bien sûr
sur tous les points de vue financiers
sur les textes de loi sur les textes
réglementaires parce que on a le devoir
aussi
d'accompagner nos populations sur la
conscience collective voilà et ça c'est
un point quand même qui est très
important
face à certains élus ou d'autres
qui nous expliquent
nous racontons des histoires et que on
ne risque rien qu'on va nous défendre
absolument voilà ce que je veux aussi
rajouter merci
bien mais s'il n'y a plus de questions
moi je tiens franchement à remercier nos
trois intervenants c'était parti c'était
particulièrement intéressant je crois
que on a devant nous un grand chantier
on avait d'ailleurs sur ces
problématiques de l'eau
à travers Hervé Gillet et puis Rémi
pointeaux anticipé puisqu'il y a une
mission
de la mission de la Commission sur
effectivement la problématique liée à
l'eau qui est un sujet qui doit nous
préoccuper énormément et sur lesquels on
doit alerter nos populations parce que
c'est vrai que cette problématique elle
est peut-être pas vu par tout le monde
comme comme elle devrait l'être
aujourd'hui alors merci parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que là c'est problématiques
vont si rien n'est fait vont engendrer
un déplacement de de population et tout
cela déplacement de population et autres
et je crois que la gestion de l'eau est
fond mental et vous pouvez compter sur
l'expertise de notre commission pour
essayer de travailler au mieux sur ce
sujet important
[Musique]